are you doing today let's start with
that I'm doing great
me first of all I want to I want to
thank you so much for coming in to talk
about your movie there's so much I want
to get to and I think that the people
that read Collider and watch Collider
they've heard about your movie for a
long time they're familiar because
they're cinephiles they know how movies
are made and all the stuff that can
happen behind the scenes your movie has
an interesting story yeah I'm gonna use
the term interesting because I saw your
film at the Toronto Film Festival I
believe two years ago and since that
time it's you know you've done some
additional photography you've reddit
'add and the version I recently saw
being honest was so much better like I
really like it just worked for me so
much more
so could you sort of talk about I guess
the long process or what this adventure
has been like for you to get your film
which is again really good into theatres
um it was it was a surreal journey very
painful at times but ultimately I'm so
you know I had to go this was the
journey of this film I just it had to go
through maybe hopefully it won't be as
painful you know like you know the next
one will be is painful but it just this
was the journey of this film and I'm
just really lucky to have been able to
rework it and without any of the chaos
in any of the notes and and and just
been able to actually do the work and
and and and follow through with the the
film that I saw in my head and when the
film I intended to make to begin with
and I was able to get there as close as
one can you know but I really do feel
like I gave my best this is my version
it's the best version I was able to make
and I I truly love it and I'm really
proud of it but it to get there was was
you know TIFF was a very difficult
evening sure absolutely
before we go any further I think people
some people have seen the trailers but
how have you been like mentioning it to
friends and family in terms of like what
the film is about the film is like I
didn't I didn't set out to movie to make
a movie about electricity after me in
Orland dying girl that was but I loved
the characters and I loved the themes of
the film
of this battle between ego and humility
and will be bad ambition and legacy and
immortality and and at the time and
still today I was still working through
some themes about mortality in that I
started to kind of explore Indian are
all and and and I found that there was a
piece of them in me and not in intellect
or talent or anything like that but it
ambition and humility and this fight
between them as you know filmmakers and
and wanting to make work that lasts but
also wanted to make maybe work that
maybe changed some minds and and in
addition to that it was this social
network 1893 it was about the future not
about the past it was a chance to make a
period movie that had of constant energy
and a contemporary feel to it as opposed
to something that was stodgy and still
and and I thought it was incredibly
relevant today with and with the
streaming wars or just the double-edged
sword of technology and in the film you
have the light bulb leads to the
electric chair and and and it's just the
the dark side of Technology and the
consequences and the responsibility of
those behind them completely I have so
many things I want to get to but let's
first start with your insane cast when
we look at the poster the UK poster I
should point out behind us you can see
the faces you put in this movie it's
preposterous how you got all these
people in the movie and even on the side
you have Tom Hall yeah yeah it's it's
crazy so talk a little bit about landing
this cast you know a Benedict was
attached to the movie when I read the
screenplay and he and I remember had a
really long Skype he was about to his
boy was about to give birth and and he
was in London and I was in LA or text as
I forget where I was and we just bonded
over I just explained how I saw the film
and and we just bonded over that and we
were in sync and we decided to move
ahead and then it was just about finding
that that right kind of rock-and-roll
combination because he want this film to
have that kind of a youthful energy and
Allen Lewis cast a film with Theo Park
who was based in London and we were
coming up with like couples and you know
the references were always
like Jagger and Dylan and Bowie is Tesla
you know as opposed to look-alikes or
anything like that it was like the
spirit of the time and and the first
thing she said to me was Michael Shannon
Kathryn Waterston that's a you know like
a rock and roll couple they look great
together and then they both said yes you
know we met a man I met Shannon at a bar
in Brooklyn Kathryn and I Skyped and we
just we just felt we just who everybody
was in sync and Tom I just want to ask
you a quick question
you you obviously you're coming off
mineral and the dying girl a lot of buzz
people love it but you're still like a
quote-unquote new filmmaker what is it
like like sitting down with Michael
Shannon at the bar knowing man I really
want him to be in my movie like are you
nervous as you're sitting down with you
so like I love actors I absolutely adore
actors so I'm just in awe of what
they're capable of doing and no I think
I don't know I think real passion is
infectious I guess you can't pretend to
want someone in film you just have to
look him in the eyes and then express
how you feel
and if they don't if they don't sign on
it just wasn't meant to be but but it's
not like I'm I'm pretending to want him
in the film because someone is telling
me to cast someone who it really came
from the heart and I think that that
speaks for itself and that can convince
isn't even the right word you know you
just want to be you would just want to
make something together that's what it's
all about you know just that the movie
is about creation and about making
things at last maybe and so as long as
we're in sync you just get a feel for it
you know and then Tom I'd known I had a
brief meeting with him once many years
ago after he made the impossible and it
was him and his mom because he was still
too young and and she was always someone
that I that I had in mind and when the
role of Samuel Insull
Samuel Insull was written into the
script it was perfect 21 year old
British kid who admired Edison - moved
to New Jersey to work for him it was
perfect and he was the first call and he
had just wrapped spider-man is a it's
it's very his star has only risen yeah
since filming this yeah so I'm sure
that's gonna help you know what I mean
yeah the cast is great one of the things
that I really took away from the film is
even from the very opening scene like
the production design yeah the way you
move your camera there's a it's all
really I don't want to curse but F and
good you know what I mean talk a little
about the production design on the film
because you immediately are submerged
into this time and era it was but we
interpreted the whole idea was to
interpret the time not to make an exact
replica of the the spaces if we would
find archival footage or a lot of this
was pre motion pictures so still
photography but it was about capturing
the spirit of the time can we what did
it feel like in that moment which was
about looking ahead not looking back and
see pure black and white or you know I
did for a moment I did think about doing
in black and white so first of all Yan
Rolf's is a production designer and
Chung Ling Chun is the cinematographer
Yan designed all the great Peter
Greenaway movies the cook the wife and
thief and lover and and then in Cheung
of course did the original old boy for
director Park Chang Luke and he didn't
mean role and we didn't like three
things together now and he's a real
brother and we did look at each other we
understand what we what we want out of
this movie which was no rules that was
the rule behind it there were gonna be
no rules and and so because everyone was
thinking out of the box we in and rich
colors and and in our palette was early
experimental color photography so it was
kind of imperfect but rich and saturated
at times and and the the movement oh you
know even though we designed them film
in pre-production storyboard it
carefully we would then kind of forget
it it was a draft in the back of our
heads and once we came on set we try to
realize those those original ideas and
some key movements that get me from one
scene to another and other times just be
in the moment with the actors and and at
that point we have we reverted to
handheld that just it just felt because
it felt right there was no one saying
that we couldn't mix form not formats
but mixed a dolly or handheld or lens
selection it just whatever felt and I
was always also composing for mother
nature who was another character in the
film and the ultimate winner of the war
so there's always air around
actors at times and sometimes in extreme
ways and that was just like fun little
exercises that we were playing with it
going into it one that let's let's break
down actually the very beginning of the
movie which is this great setup of where
you have all these lights in a field and
all these people coming in can you sort
of tell people about this specific scene
sure and a little bit of how you shot it
because it's just really cool yeah it's
the opening of the scene it's it's it's
Edison and bailing his his new invention
you know the captured yet again light in
the jar the impossible you know the
elusive he trapped it yet again and he's
always defying nature especially when
his wife to get sick and his acceptance
of her fate all that is really something
that is that is is is a theme that is
that is constant in the film too but
there again when a memory is now
captured in a motion picture you know
but the opening is is again its mother
nature begins the story you know with
the the Niagara Falls and then the the
night sky with the stars and then that's
interrupted by an extreme close up of
the westinghouse of railway air brake
like industrialization coming in and
that's the introduction really of that
character through machinery and then you
find the fat cats all these wealthy East
Coast investors approaching an empty
field at night lit up only by a
anaesthetise invoker carrying a gas
light and candlelight sorry and and you
know so mother nature takes over most of
the frame with a little train or the the
fat cats walking in the bottom of the
frame
it's kind of an F view than mother
nature's saying right from the very
beginning I will I will always win but
try kind of a things and then and then
once the Edison worker blows out the
candle and the fat cats are in the
middle of this muddy field you hear
Edison call out to his to his boys to
switch on attest to turn the switch on I
guess and and this
miraculous field of electric light
floods you know fills the screen is like
an the introduction of modernism or
futurism whatever it is and this and
it's that's our introduction to or one
of our leaves which is Edison and then a
Knopf he goes to Washington after that
to get more money what's funny about
this and I want to add this is that as
good as your description was it doesn't
fully convey how cool it looks on film
so I want to just for the people that
are watching it looks awesome it's like
a great opening to the movie it was it
was supposed to be an operatic moment
one of the few moments throughout the
film that is you know we shot it with a
crane a very specific movement that
introduces Edison I wanted it because it
really is tells a lot about the
character too because at Westinghouse as
a factory man one of his men you always
see him at his either his wife and
partner Marguerite or as one of the men
and this is Edison as the show I mean
it's all about him and it really is a
showman and it's like the in and so but
it should it should be spectacular and
then then it ends with an overhead of
God's point of view before we cut to the
title card again mother nature's always
around and there's there's a there's
another layer of death and mortality and
you know that complements the legacy
that they're both focused on in
different ways so I want to jump
backwards and the you want to go back to
the Toronto Film Festival which I'm sure
is not the best thing it's a lot about
TSD but go ahead yeah so what I want to
know is and I think people want to know
is when you showed it there mhm
from what I understand and maybe I'm
wrong it was like kind of a rush to make
that date or to get that screening done
is that what actually happened yeah
that's a that's yes that we were rushing
to get to make to make that deadline and
there was a lot of negotiation and
compromise leading up to the cut that
was still a work in progress but I knew
before I screened it that I was already
off a different track and the movie that
I intended to make was here and there
was a lot of negotiation to get it to a
place where
where I look to lose I was under the I
was delusional abit I guess I thought
because it was a work in progress and
the release was gonna be about two
months after the screening that I would
have time to continue fighting and and
winning and and steering it back to
where I wanted it to be and and it
didn't work out that way
so the I don't want it it's okay yeah
talk about everything
no no completely but so my question is
what was in that version for people that
didn't see it that you felt like
immediately like well this is stuff that
I would rather not have in it do you
know what I mean 100% unearned
sentimentality that was forced in either
in voiceover ADR wrong performance takes
to soften the fear of being Edison
unlikable and when when that is part of
his character and that what that's what
makes the conflict so real is and and
what and we're now and I hope people
agree with me that Edison's and I mean
Benedict's performance is so layered and
it's so dark but at you and now that you
understand how he thinks and why he's
making the choices that he's making and
how ambition is starting to take over
all that was lost and it was softened
kind of neutering the movie making it
quite flat in addition to that we were
still be working that the music wasn't
there yet and we shot five additional
scenes for the us cut and yet the film
is still 10 minutes shorter than would
screen there and and scenes just needed
time a couple of things needed movie
just needed shape the scenes needed work
when you're noted to death sometimes you
can you can lose yourself any artist
sometimes loses yourself and you just
need time for your to work just
literally to work and not address notes
but to work in silence have your ideas
settle and I had that time
unintentionally but this was the journey
I needed this is the time I needed for
all the ideas to settle and find my way
back and I was lucky enough to get a
chance to we work the movie the way I
intended well it's fascinating to me
because anyone who's watched my
interviews knows I constantly talked
about the editing process with
filmmakers because it's essentially the
final rewrite
your film is a perfect example of why
editing is so important because I'm one
of those few that saw the TIF cut and I
remember talking to you that night and
being him I don't want to actually say
what I that that night but what I was
gonna say that I remember leaving the
theater and being like I see the movie
it doesn't fully work for me yeah like
there's something about like you know
what I mean but like there was so much
good in it and but since you've done the
reading I'm like oh this is really good
and it's probably because of things that
I didn't even realize which you've
mentioned which is alt takes of
Benedict's performance everyone needs
every ID or actors and they need time
and this was a very fragile film and it
had an unusual structure as well and we
were trying to to make the film and
release it within less than a year which
is very hard for a movie like this as
sometimes needs a little more time to
find that balance because you can move a
Tesla scene this way and a Westinghouse
in that way in the movie still kind of
works but there's only one right
combination that makes it work the best
and that needed time to sort out and and
and all the performance needed to tweak
and and and really spend time looking at
the footage and finding the right
balance to make to make them feel real
totally so you mentioned you did some
additional photography what did you
shoot that add it to the movie and how
did it help the film a lot of choices
help the film and Danny Benson journey
and Saunders did wrote an incredible
score and I always wanted the music to
be aggressive and loud and and have the
music be another character that helps
obviously that adds another layer and
another character you always wanted the
film to have instead of being something
stately and we shot five new scenes that
really clarified the relationship or to
help define the relationship between
Edison and his wife Mary played by
tuppence Middleton and understand her
illness a little better and and that was
key one new scene with with Nikola Tesla
where he's fired and and there's a great
line that says it you know you're just
an immigrant which only add
didn't help then underscore the themes
of the fence and there that it run
throughout the film both offensive Mary
wanted in a virtual fence that that that
the West Westinghouse speaks of by the
end in addition to that scenes that
babies that I lost that that all of a
sudden the film that that the movie just
distorted to find the right shape find
the right rhythm and and there was a
moment where my body just kind of tells
you just kind of told you at some point
I think this is it and we finally found
the right shape of the film and it's in
it's time to let it out to let it go and
I can still you know I could I'm still
trying to get a shot from the second
season of Glee that I you know for a
shot that I didn't get you know with the
AV kids and the Christmas episode I'm
still I'm still trying to get that shot
so I continue mixing this her as long as
you want but but it did feel like this
is right and we started screening it and
it in the response was was was different
it was there it was energetic it was
they people understood the themes better
the beauty and the dreams and the pathos
everything just kind of the pathos
everything just kind of started to to
click and at some point out it was it
was it was ready
and I know I know that I gave my best
completely but as I said I'm one of
those few that there's only probably a
number like a thousand people or five
hundred people or I don't know many
people were in the theater if you don't
have a thousand and it's amazing how
that can destroy one one screening can
just absolutely be devastated yeah I
mean but that's why I'm being so
proactive yes because I it I really
enjoyed this new cut and so I really do
hope people I do think with this cast
that people are gonna watch it I mean
you can't this is just an incredible
cast and once you start it with the
production is like it just you pull into
this world you know you must have a lot
of deleted scenes yeah I can so do you
have is there a is there a scene that
you were really sad to see go but it
just didn't work for the movie that's a
great questions I love those questions
myself but
last a couple of scenes in for the
director's cut of the film that I was
holding on to in fact you probably saw
them that that rhythmically were wrong
and as an experiment at Westinghouse
used to have used to have a different
introduction at a party and and now he's
introduced in a very quiet domestic
scene with his wife that is so
appropriate to the character as opposed
to the more kind of you know Visconti's
the leopard version of it yeah as
beautiful as that was it rhythmically
was wrong it was beautiful but
thematically and for character purposes
this new version seems like a quiet
introduction of this man
after seeing Edison the field just seems
right other than that it was um there
were certain sequences they were much
longer at the south of brown the
humanitarian who is proposing that
Edison collaborate with him on the
electric chair because he sees he's been
seeing so much of a botched hangings he
had a longer sequence in the botched
hanging sea but I just loved because it
was so dark and macabre and I and I
think a quicker version of that hat is
the right thing for the movie but the
longer when I could live in there
forever plus it Michael Wilkins since
costumes are amazing hit this like mob a
suede situation I am a top hat I think
did I see that yeah I think I saw that
scene or did I not it was it's always
been this the compressed version but
there were earlier versions that I could
just live in it forever because that's
so interesting he's a beautiful actor
Tom Fisher yeah I'm just thinking about
the this stuff yeah anyway I want to
jump into something else which is your
history you've worked with such gifted
filmmakers as a second unit director as
an assistant you're and I think a lot of
people may not realize mean if you don't
mind name-dropping but named some of the
people you've worked for us like an
assistant um there's a lot of a grape
yep I'm very lucky I don't know how I
got a seat at the table but but people I
left Laredo Texas because of mean
streets and and the gentleman on your
shirt of course says he changed my his
movies changed my life when I discovered
them on VHS and I decided to
kind of follow his path and go to New
York and Faber and Faber Scorsese on
Scorsese was my Bible you know and and
and I ended up working as an intern and
eventually as an assistant to him and
and then badla to Thummim Schoonmaker
which leads to Nick pledgie pledgie
married to Nora Ephron and and
eventually Nora Ephron gets me into the
DGA shooting second unit for her which I
did until the very end you know I was
already directing I think American
horror and but and if she would call and
say do you mind sheeting some food
inserts for Julie and Julie I get on the
next flight and just do like the best
insert of a duck you've ever seen and
then and then Ryan Murphy of course you
know he saw I did second year directed
second unit for him some sequences in
India and in Bali for beat Pray Love and
has show Glee had just been picked up I
think the back nine of the first season
and he asked if I wanted to do a shoot
an episode for him and I assumed it was
a one-off but that became the beginning
of my directing career which led to
American Horror Story and eventually my
own work yeah it's it's it went and also
the Big L so another one hundred goats
how that scene yari to who who
originally needed I had a friend who had
a friend who knew that he's starting a
movie in Memphis 21 grams and he needed
a bilingual assistant he knew I spoke
Spanish and I met with him and then we
hit it off and then I end up doing
secondary not babble and now he's been a
great friend and supporter since then
it's crazy I mean literally your story
is the American dream it's allow me
would I have loved to finish the rap you
know graduate from NYU with like a
picture deal at a studio yes my journey
was just slower but I've been so lucky
because I've been enriched by these
these beautiful human beings that just
happen also be the best filmmakers but
think about it like you you grew up
being a Scorsese fan yes and you worked
for Scorsese yeah I mean that shit's
crazy when I remember when I went to uh
I think there was a counselor at a what
do you call these guidance counselors at
at NYU my first week you had to meet
with them and I said and he said what he
want to do is I want to work for
Scorsese and he's like every single
person around you is here for the same
reason he just fell in god he's right
but I kept trying trying to eventually
eventually it's a longer story how do I
got them in that door but it's a good
one but but I got there right so you
worked with such gifted filmmakers and
people what is it is there a similar
trait that a lot of these people have
that you wanted to take with you for
your own work and also just as a person
yeah because you can't copy style
everyone all these filmmakers see the
world through their own lenses and I
hope I do too so it's not about that and
and everyone runs their set differently
every one of them and that's always
fascinating to see what works for you
what doesn't work for you but look it's
it comes out to humility it really is
that how you know generous they have
been and how humble you know Scorsese
you know you have a conversation he'll
he'll mention all the Masters that came
before him you know before he says
anything about his own work there and is
this this wanting to expose you to film
history that that love of film history
and everything that's come before and
and and that is a part of a great
quality of his and Thelma Schoonmaker
and that kind of nurturing and thumb has
been a guardian angel for for the last
20 years in my life and and everybody
else has had in why why Nora brought me
into the rehearsals and and why did she
force Paramount to get me into the guild
P she insisted I was the only person
that could direct second unit for her
they just had faith and so it's it's
it's a quality that I hope I have and
that I hope to be able to pass on yeah I
definitely wanna touch on a series that
I'm incredibly looking forward to is the
Amazon series the hunt which I believe
you directed the pilot yes for people
that don't know where I believe it takes
place in the 70s it's about these people
that are going on the hunt for Nazi
criminals right we're not CIA
is that accurate that's accurate okay so
um how did you get involved in this
series and this is especially
appropriate in today's era yeah it's um
it I think
and this is something you should check
before you run this I think there
retitling it hunters or the hunters sure
because there's a blonde house film
called the hunt yes okay and I think
it's going to be hunters so basically
why don't we just say it's untitled for
now untitled for now but but I think I
think they've settled on hunters by the
way so hunters
I was sent the script and I was it was
hard for me to take on another movie
because current war I was still reading
it in my head and I hadn't been released
yet so no one had ripped it away from me
yet and I was still hoping and I just
needed to make that movie the version
that I saw in my head so I didn't want
to take another film or work on another
film you know was writing quite a bit
and then when I was submitted a pilot
script which was a feature-length pilot
of a not a pilot but the first of ten
episodes that I met with David Wilder
Rider and Nikki Toscano who was a exec
producer with David I liked them very
much
I liked the material and I very much and
and I started to see it in my head and I
had a dream of casting Pacino as Maya
Offerman one of the leads in the film
and and I became real and so that was a
that was one of the highlights of my
life is to be able to collaborate with
him and get to know him and work with
him that's the thing when you do the
pilot you're very involved in every
aspect so talk a little bit logan lerman
I and the other people that you put in
the show yeah yeah that's the the great
part of directing a pilot is that you
are there from the ground up and you are
assembling with the showrunners the the
cast and the crew and in this case
rehearsals and the palette the color
palette all those choices and creating a
prototype that that they hope will
survive and last and and one that other
directors could could take and and make
their own and interpret it because it's
their artist too but there is a certain
direction and I also got to work with
Fred Elms on the pilot who shot some of
my favorite movies of all time for
when she raised her head and blue velvet
and did the ice storm in all the last
few Jim Jarmusch movie and he's been one
of my heroes and he was available and we
worked together on this pilot but Jeanne
Berlin is in at Logan Lerman was amazing
Carol Kane who was unbelievable I mean
the it's a beautiful beautiful cast and
it's tonally I think a will unique piece
the the series is is it one of these
things where the rating doesn't really
apply or is it like would you I mean how
would you describe the tone and what
you're gonna kind of see on screen um I
don't know anything about ratings or
anything like that in it and and I think
it gets I could be all drop I think in
the winter it's it's it's Amazon and and
and I'm not I'm not aware of I don't
think they have a rating on TV I'm
wondering more about like tone and is it
one of these things where we're gonna
see these people like I guess how much
do you see I think you see a lot I mean
I think there's it's a fine line between
Marathon Man and and a graphic novel you
know so there is some extreme violence
but there is some humor and and and
there is tonally it's a challenge
because there are flashbacks to
concentration camp so you have to to
honor the why behind making this project
and also creating something that that
that feels a new and-and-and and unique
Lily what have you been obviously
wrapped on that a while ago what have
you been working on since well this well
the hunt 'im I I'm still mixing it
because it's a feature-length pilot so
we're finally finalizing the mix and so
it's like an hour and a half to two
hours it's an hour and a half yeah and
then before that eight a pilot the first
two episodes of a show for Netflix
called chambers with Alma Thurman that
was a lot of fun and Tony Goldwyn and a
lot of wonderful young actors um some
cast right out of the Native American
reservations it was a really great
experience and then and now I'm just
thinking about the next thing it's nice
to finally let this film go I'm really
proud of it and it feels like a triumph
for the cast and the crew that made it
with me
to have to finally have something out
there that regardless I would to receive
that you know you put you did your best
and their best work and I'm really
thrilled with it and I'm just thinking
about the next thing you know hopefully
it'll be an easier process but I'm
willing to take a chance of it isn't I I
know I could survive it what's
interesting is that you are in the boat
of there's some filmmakers are spoken to
that are like once once it's done it's
done and I believe you're probably more
in the Lucas boat of like I can still
tweak this at some point at some point
when it's actually released you know
that you did the best under the
circumstances under this conditions
period that was what I was thinking two
years ago and that was a horrible
feeling because that was not me and now
is very much me and and I do move on but
up until it's actually released I will
try to do to perfect it and yeah unless
it's that shoftim Glee that I will never
it was like it was so cz it was a shot
of the AV kids looking up with a little
snow machine Lea you know Michelle
singing this carpenter song but I'll try
to get it someday that's so funny it
aired eight years ago I think that's so
funny
well listen up for the people watching I
really recommend giving current more a
chance please
October 25th in select theaters two
thousand theaters across the nation and
it's everywhere yeah I'm really excited
about it it's it's it kind of celebrates
the medium that that we're using to make
it in there's another story about the
creation of motion pictures so if you're
a fan of films I hope you dig this one
thank you so much for coming in the
studio and thank you all so much for
watching